and read jetpack is a set of libraries
and guidance for modern Android
development now there are four
categories that make up jetpack this
video is all about architecture here are
the architecture component libraries
these libraries work great on their own
but they're also built with each other
in mind and can fit together like puzzle
pieces the documentation contains a
guide to app architecture which shows
one way that these puzzle pieces can
combined to create a testable and
maintainable app this architecture
revolves around the following principles
the separation of concerns loose
coupling the observer pattern and
inversion of control okay let's go ahead
and start at the bottom room is a sequel
light object mapping library it gives us
annotations to generate boilerplate code
for you you declare your sequel light
tables using entity objects entity
objects are just simple objects with a
few annotations for example I could take
this class representing a user and after
add a few annotations it becomes a
representation for this sequel like
table schema when defining the
operations you perform audio database
you essentially write annotated sequel
statements this is where rooms object
mapping capabilities come in
you can put entity objects directly into
your room database or have your database
return entities no conversion or
intermediates were needed compile type
checking is also included so if you mess
up your sequel like queries rule lets
you know right away room also supports
observable queries including arcs travel
flow bowls lists optionals and guava
classes migration between schemas and
testing another fundamental part of any
data layer is threading and background
work to make sense of background work in
modern android development we've created
the guide to background processing which
includes this handy table you'll notice
that there's this new library here work
manager the work manager library
provides a unified API for deferrable
one-off or recurring background tasks
that need guaranteed execution the
background tasks are work request
objects with work manager you can build
a complex processing and upload flow
like this using chains of work requests
as part of the chain you can define the
output of one
our requests as the input of another
worker crust you can also set conditions
on when the work request should run work
manager then performs the work requests
in the order that you specify it while
also taking care of compatibility issues
and best practices for battery and
system health as part of guaranteed
execution work manager handles continue
your work across device restarts and if
your process is for stopped finally work
manager can return the state of the work
request so that you can represent this
state in your UI okay let's go ahead and
take a look at the lifecycle libraries
the classes in this library help with
Android lifecycle management
specifically with avoiding memory leaks
when updating your apps UI here is one
example
have you ever rotated advice and had the
app crash or lose data well adding a
view model can help fix this unlike
activity objects a view model object
isn't destroyed when the device
configuration changes such as when the
screen is rotated this property of view
model makes it a good stable place to
put all of your UI data the view model
usually contains another lifecycle
object live data live data is built for
easy communication between the UI and
deeper layers of your apps architecture
life data is an observable data holder
for data that is meant to be showed on
screen basically it'll wrap around an
object like this user object over here
and allow the UI to automatically update
whatever properties of the user object
change live data is also life cycle
aware this means a live data object only
tells the UI to update if the UI is
lifecycle state is in the correct State
for example if your activity is not
unscreened then the live data will not
trigger updates also if the activity
gets destroyed then this observation
connection is cleaned up for you
automatically so as your data changes
you never accidentally trigger an
activity or fragment that is off-screen
or destroyed to redraw itself the
lifecycle libraries include other
powerful features for example live data
supports transformations as mentioned
before room can return live data objects
which allows your UI to observe objects
in the database view models and live
data also now support data binding you
can bind these classes to an element in
your apps XML layout definition that
lets you get rid
all of this boilerplate code the
lifecycles library also contains classes
at interfaces for quitting and observing
UI lifecycle states the paging library
integrates directly with rube and live
data now there's a common situation
where you have a lot of data that you
want to load in small manageable chunks
the paging library is built exactly for
this use case and it avoids tricky
sequel like cursor performance issues
the library offers the following
features it allows you to define the
data sources that you're going to use be
it data from the network a database or
another data source of your choice it
works out of the box with room and
recycler view it supports lists of any
size including lists of infinite length
it leverages live data to update your UI
as more data is loaded and it has
support for arcs Java finally there's
the navigation library the navigation
library and tooling simplify
implementation of complex but common
navigation requirements and help you
visualize your apps navigation graph now
for trivial apps navigation might seem
simple but when you add things like
fragment transactions the need to
implement proper back and up behavior
support deep linking at a bottom bar and
include animations between screens let's
just say that things get a little bit
messy the navigation library simplifies
all of this now the basic building
blocks for navigation are called
destinations destinations are specific
screens you can go to there's
out-of-the-box support for fragments and
activities as destinations but you can
also make your own the new guide to
navigation encourages you to have
activities as entry points for your app
they also contain global navigation such
as this bottom death now in comparison
fragments will be the actual destination
specific layouts this UI structure
allows you to share an activity view
model between all of the fragments
associated with that activity as the
user navigates from fragment to fragment
you don't need to serialize that shared
data the new navigation editor in
Android studio enables you to quickly
specify destinations and visualize your
apps navigation architecture the
connections here show the possible
navigation paths between each
destination this generates XML which you
can edit by hand the library uses this
new navigation graph resore
and a new nav controller object to move
your user through your app now this is
just scratching the surface of the
proverbial iceberg that is the
architecture components and jetpack
hopefully some or maybe all of these
libraries piqued your interest to learn
more
we've got dev bytes for all of the
stable components we also have code labs
for each component and of course
thorough documentation now if you find
yourself left with questions we've also
got Stack Overflow tags and an issue
tracker or you know you can yell at me
on Twitter actually don't yell at me in
Twitter happy coding
[Applause]
you